man: Hello.
Hello, and welcome
to the Android
Open Accessories talk.
Um, I'm glad you all came.
[cheers and applause]
man: So welcome
to the secret talk.
So as you heard
in this morning's keynote,
we've been doing a lot of work
on Android, um,
to make it more open
and to enable, um,
users and developers
to make use of more
and different
interesting peripherals,
um, over USB.
So, you know,
previously with Android,
um, you know,
the Android device supported
a certain number of, um,
of interfaces.
You could connect to it
as a USB mass storage device.
You could connect to it, um,
to run the Android Debug Bridge
and so forth.
Uh, but now we've extended
those capabilities
with new APIs,
um, and--and new capabilities
to attach accessories
and to connect to, uh,
traditional host-mode
USB device peripherals.
So I'm actually gonna
start this talk.
Um, I should introduce myself.
My name is Jeff Brown.
I'm a member
of the Android framework team.
And this is Mike Lockwood.
He's also a member
of the Android framework team.
And Erik Gilling
from the Android systems team.
So I'm gonna--
I'm gonna talk about, um,
input devices.
So we've got USB,
which, you know,
USB host mode,
which means now we have access
to all of the interesting,
standard USB peripherals
that you're used to on a PC.
So I've got, um,
a USB keyboard here,
and I've got a USB mouse.
So these are--
these are wireless,
and hopefully, it works.
[laughs]
And, um, they're
currently plugged in, uh,
the--the dongles are plugged
into a standard USB hub.
So all right, you know,
pretty much
what you would expect.
We've got a USB keyboard.
We should be able
to use it to type.
All right, so I've got
the AK Notepad application
from Android Market.
I'm just gonna use this
as a basic text editor.
So all right--keyboard.
I love Android...
sort of.
[laughter]
Brown: Well,
I definitely love Android.
Brown: Um, so you've got a--
so you've got a keyboard.
So you can do
all the basic things
you would expect to do
with a keyboard,
um, you know, control-C,
copy, paste, all that stuff.
Um, it would help if I actually
could see what I was doing.
There we are.
It's a keyboard.
Um, we've also got a mouse.
So you've got your mouse cursor
going around.
Um, we support the scroll wheel,
and there's new APIs
that applications can use
to listen to hover events
from the mouse
and scroll events.
Um, this is implemented
in, um, all of the standard
framework widgets,
so you can scroll through lists.
Um, you can also scroll
around, uh, web browser pages.
So now that you've got,
you know, a keyboard and mouse,
and you can attach your tablet
to a, uh, an HDMI display,
you don't need
your laptop anymore.
So one other thing
I want to talk about,
uh, which was mentioned
during the keynote,
is that we also support
game controllers.
Um, so we now have new APIs
for--for joysticks.
Um, there's a new callback
that you can use--
you can register in your views
called onGenericMotionEvent,
and it exposes
all the various,
uh, joystick axes,
um, that exist
on a game controller.
Um, it also works on,
you know, flight sticks
and other things like that.
Uh, we've got over 30
different axes plumbed through,
um, including, you know,
throttle controls.
If you've got a, uh,
a car-driving rig,
um, that works.
Um, 3-D positioning mouse
is kind of like a joystick.
It's just got six axes.
Um, so you can--you can listen
to these in your app, as well.
So I'm just gonna show you
very quickly
a-a simple API demo sample.
So you already saw this morning
the joystick being used
to run "Quordy."
Um, but we have a little sample
that's in the Honeycomb 3.1 SDK,
um, which demonstrates
sort of all of the data
that you can get
out of a joystick.
so on the left-hand pane,
uh, we've got a list of axes.
So there's some new APIs
that you can use
to enumerate the input devices
that are present on the system
and query the capabilities,
query the axes that are
available on joysticks,
query the buttons
that are available
and--and their ranges.
And on the right,
I've got a very simple
physics-based game. [laughs]
So, um, anyway,
that's--that's pretty much it
for input devices for now.
And I'm going
to hand off to,
uh, Erik Gilling,
who's gonna tell you more
about how USB really works
and, uh, what all
we can do with it.
Gilling: Thanks, Jeff.
All right, so we've got
two more really exciting,
uh, accessory things
to talk about,
but to really appreciate
the difference
between both of them,
I want to lay the groundwork
by getting us all
on the same page
with how USB works
from a very high level.
Um, on USB, there's a host
and a collection of devices.
It's, uh, important to know
the host is always in charge.
It has to keep track
of when things are plugged in,
taken out, what kinds
of things are in there.
It initiates all data transfer.
So the host is always in charge.
The way the host keeps track
and figures out
what kind of devices
are plugged in
is when they plug in,
it reads a list of descriptors.
Now descriptors
are a standard format,
uh, in the USB spec
of, uh, you know,
a bunch of different types.
They're hierarchical.
So you start with--
each device
has one device descriptor.
This describes who made it,
what kind of product it is,
whether it's a standard
class of device,
or it's
a vendor-specific device,
and a couple of strings that
you can display to the user.
A device can have
more than one configuration,
though on most Android devices,
you'll only see one.
Uh, and you can only be in
one configuration at one time.
Now a configuration
has a list of interfaces,
and this is where things
get interesting.
Interfaces generally pair
one-to-one
with a driver
in your operating system.
So you can think of a mouse
and keyboard combo
with, like, a track pad
on your keyboard.
Each one of those will be
a separate interface.
They'll both be input devices,
each one having an instance
that the input driver connected.
And then an interface
is composed
of several descriptors.
And now here's where your data
starts moving.
They have four different types.
They have a direction.
They have a max packet size.
Um, and--yeah,
so we've got four--
our four different types.
Control is primarily used
to get at those descriptors,
add enumeration,
when you put a device in,
interrogate the device,
set it up.
You can have some vendor-
specific control requests.
Uh, bulk, which are
really the workhorses
of the USB.
Uh, you can send just bulk data
of fairly large sizes
either in or out,
only one direction per endpoint.
If you want to do bidirectional,
you need two endpoints.
Then there's interrupt,
which are very similar
to your bulk endpoints.
Uh, the only difference here
is that, uh, they're polled
much more often,
remembering the host
is always in control.
Every single data transfer
is initiated by the host,
so you don't want to send
much data over these.
But for things
like your input devices--
keyboards, mice, joysticks--
they use the interrupt
so that when you press
that button
to kill your friend in "Quake"
it actually happens on time.
And then isochronous,
which are used for things
like audio.
They're a real pain
to deal with,
and forget about them now.
Brown: [chuckles]
Gilling: So, uh,
So as I said, we have
two different kinds of, uh,
accessory APIs coming up.
To talk about the first one,
the host mode,
I'm gonna give it over
to Mike Lockwood.
Lockwood:
[speaking indistinctly]
I'm here at, um, at Google.
Um, we've got two new APIs,
um, for USB
in Android 3.1.
The first one I'm gonna
talk about is the host API,
and this is for Android devices
that have USB host support.
Um, it won't do any good on--
on devices that only act
as the device.
Um, and this can be used
for writing apps
that can communicate
with standard, um, peripherals
designed for a PC.
Or you could develop
new pieces of hardware
that, um,
specifically for Android,
um, and use these APIs
with that.
Lockwood: Um, so the API has
a number of new classes to it.
Um, the first three correspond
directly to some
of the descriptors
that Erik just talked about.
There is a UsbDevice,
um, class
that has the vendor ID
and product ID.
Um, you first--you know,
when something gets plugged in,
you'd look at that and say, um,
"This is something
I'm interested in talking to."
And you can do that based
on the vendor ID and product ID
or maybe based on the device
class, subclass, and protocol,
which are usually used
to define, you know,
standard types of things,
like mice, keyboards, cameras,
um, where you don't really know
what the manufac--
care what the manufacturer is,
but you care
more about the, um,
the functionality it has.
Um, and then from
the UsbDevice class
you can get a list
of the interfaces,
and that also can have a class,
subclass, and protocol field
you might be interested in.
And then finally,
from the interface,
you get a list
of the endpoints.
And the two we care about here
are the--the bulk
and interrupt,
um, endpoint types.
Those are the type
you'd normally use.
Um, each of these
have a specific direction.
You know, if you want
to talk in both directions,
you have to have one endpoint
in the out direction,
which means, um, PC to device
or host to device,
and then in
is from device to host.
Um, and then two more classes--
um, the UsbDeviceConnection
and the UsbRequest classes.
Um, the UsbDeviceConnection
is kind of like
a file descriptor
when you open--
it's something used that you--
when you open the device,
um, this lets you communicate
and send data back and forth
across the endpoints.
Another important thing
is the claiming
and releasing of interfaces.
The--the USB stack in Linux
has this notion
of claiming an interface,
meaning that you're specifically
talking to that interface
on the USB device,
so you don't have two programs
trying to talk to the same
hardware at the same time.
Um, and then we've got support
for both synchronous
and asynchronous communication.
Um, for
asynchronous communication,
we've got the UsbRequest class,
and that just encapsulates a,
um, a request,
either send or receive data
over a particular endpoint.
Lockwood: Um, so I'm gonna
just go quickly
through some sample code here.
Um, this--this is some code
that basically gets
the USB device
and decides,
can I talk to this?
Where are the endpoints
I want to talk to?
So first, I might look
at the vendor ID and product ID
and see if those match
some values
that I'm interested in.
Then I look
for the first interface
on the device.
Say that I should expect
two endpoints,
then I say which one's
the in direction,
and which one's
the out direction.
Then ultimately I get the EP in
and EP out,
or the two endpoints,
the two bulk endpoints
I want to talk on.
Lockwood: And then
once I have that,
there's a number of ways
to, um, actually communicate
with the device,
depending on whether you're
doing synchronous
or asynchronous,
and what kind of endpoint
you're talking on.
Um, there's a-a call--
UsbManager openDevice
gives you
the UsbDeviceConnection.
Once you do that, you want
to claim the interface.
Um, and then from there,
there's a number
of different things you can do.
There's the control transfer.
It's for sending or receiving
requests on endpoint zero.
Erik mentioned that's
typically used for enumeration
to figure out what's
available on the device.
But it also can be used
for some extensions,
either for a particular vendor
or a particular class of device.
You can send and receive, um,
your own commands on there.
Um, and the bulk transfer call--
there's--
this is a synchronous call.
It can pass on the endpoint,
the buffer, the buffer size,
and the time-out,
and either send or receive
data synchronously.
And the direction, whether
you're sending or receiving,
is determined by the direction
of the endpoint.
And then finally,
asynchronous requests,
um, are good if you want
to get higher bandwidth
on the bulk endpoints,
queue up multiple requests.
Instead of waiting
for one to finish
before starting the next one,
you can queue up
multiple requests,
and your requests, um,
and then wait for them
to, um, to, um,
either be completed,
either sending or receiving.
And also, if you're interested
in listening for interrupts
for something like the keyboard,
where you press a button,
and something happens,
that's gonna
happen asynchronously,
so you queue up a request
and then just wait--
just wait
until something happens,
and you get the USB--
the UsbRequest, um, object
gets returned back
when that's done.
And I think that's--
covers the host APIs.
And I'm gonna turn it
back over to Erik...
Gilling: Do the demo?
Lockwood: to talk
about accessories now.
Gilling: Demo?
Lockwood: Oh, the demo. God.
Gilling: The demo--
you have to do the demo.
Lockwood: See, this is why they
don't let me out very often
to talk in public.
[laughter]
Lockwood: So...
Gilling: [chuckles]
[applause]
Lockwood: And this, um,
is a standard piece
of o-office equipment
that many of you probably have
in your office yourself.
Also the second reason they
don't let me out very often,
because I end up
doing stuff like this.
So, um, this is, uh,
a USB missile launcher
that you can get at a number
of fine web sites.
Um, and it's designed
for a PC.
There's a Windows app
that runs it,
but it turns out the protocol
that it communicates with
is pretty simple.
So I've got
an Android tablet here
with host support.
I'm gonna plug it in.
Lockwood: And I get
a dialogue saying, um,
"Do you want to run
the missile launcher application
to talk to this device?"
Click "Okay," and...
I got, um, this is an example
of my UI design here.
So I hooked it up
to the accelerometer,
and I tilt the tablet,
and the missile launcher
starts turning.
[laughter]
Lockwood: Raise the trajectory
a little bit here.
And then there's a button here
called "Fire!"
[laughter]
Lockwood: There we go.
[applause]
Lockwood: After this,
I want to get a job
at the basketball games
shooting the T-shirts
into the audience.
[laughter]
Lockwood: Um, okay,
now I actually will turn it
back over to Erik,
since I'm out of missiles.
Gilling: [laughs]
Thanks, Mike.
Gilling: All right, so, uh,
you know, Jeff showed you
some cool input stuff,
and he kind of went over
a little bit
of how he got to play games
on the company time.
Mike just showed you
how he got to buy toys
on the company time.
But some of you may have seen
a big toy upstairs.
I think--not that it's
a game or anything,
but if it was, I was winning.
[laughter]
Gilling: So this brings us
to the Android Open Accessories,
which we talked about
in the keynote.
Now not every Android device
has host mode.
In fact, very few Android
devices now have host mode.
We hope more people will,
but what about for the rest
of the robots?
Well, every Android device
that is CTS-compatible
has to have ADB,
which means it has to be
a USB device.
So let's turn the paradigm
on its head.
And what if the accessory
is the host?
Well, that's exactly
what we've done
with the Open Accessory.
It's a simple USB protocol.
The accessory is the host
and, uh, provides power...
[clears throat]
Yeah. Anyway... [laughs]
Anyway, uh, so unlike Mike
and unlike Jeff,
I can't go out,
and I can't buy one of these.
So this is where ADK comes in.
It's a simple board.
It's based on the Arduino
with some USB circuitry on it.
Gilling: Let's get some light
on the subject.
Gilling: 4,3.
There we go.
Gilling: Uh, we seem
to be missing a USB cable.
Never fear. [sighs]
All right, so it's got
a simple board.
Uh, it's got the USB host shield
integrated on it.
And on top of that we've created
our own little Google shield.
Now this has a lot of fun I/O.
It's got some buttons.
It's got a joystick.
We've even bundled
a little servo in with it.
And, uh, much like
with a host accessory,
you can see
that once we pair it
with a device--
you'll notice
I'm using the Nexus S,
which is running our latest
version of Gingerbread,
which we've pushed out.
This does not have host support,
so you can't write
a host peripheral for this.
Now I'm gonna plug in
the USB connection.
And that same basic dialogue
that you saw with the host mode
peripherals opens up.
It lets us launch an app.
Gilling: Now you know, this is
a pretty simple demo app.
Um, my UI design skills
are no better
than Mike Lockwood's,
but I happened to con
one of our nice UI designers
into making this
look pretty for us, so...
Uh, you can see, you know,
we've got a bunch of I/O
going from the board
onto the device.
If we go over to the "Out" tab,
you can see we've got a bunch
of data going the other way.
Oh, green's
not particularly bo--
both green is kind of boring.
Uh, and we also have some relays
on the board here,
which you can turn on and off.
And what's a lot of fun
is some servos.
Now I've taken
this little servo--
there--
and I've put it inside
one of these little, uh,
Android figurines
that we all know and love.
So, uh, you know,
Android loves you, too.
Why don't you say hello
to everybody, Android?
[high-pitched voice] HI.
[laughter]
Gilling: So, uh,
the source code for this,
the board designs,
the firmware, and the app
are all live and released
on accessories.android.com now.
There's the tablet, uh, app.
Gilling: So in order to be
one of these peripherals,
you don't have to be an ADK.
This is just a sample.
Microchip has
a development kit out.
Other people are coming out
with development kits.
You can do it with your own
custom hardware,
as long as you're a host,
and you can provide the USB spec
worth of power,
which is 500 milliamps
at, uh, 5 volts.
To get established--
it's pretty simple.
Um, you, uh...
When you get a hotplug event,
you need to interrogate
the USB device.
And you send it one of these
vendor-specific control requests
we talked about.
This one we came up--we call it
a "Get Protocol" version.
And it just returns to you
a version number.
Now if it returns to you
a version number,
your Android device supports
the Open Accessory protocol.
If it doesn't, it doesn't.
Once you do that,
you send over data
to identify your peripheral.
USB has all of this information,
all of this procedure
for how to identify
a USB device to the host,
but there's really nothing
the other way around.
So we had to events--invent
a procedure for doing that.
You just really--you send over
your simple, basic information--
who you are,
what you are,
uh, and where to get software
for it.
You do that, and then you say,
"Okay, I'm ready to go."
Now this is a little tricky.
At this point,
your Android device
will drop off the USB bus.
Uh, and it will come back on
as a Google-specific device.
This has our Google vendor ID
and a very specific product ID.
Once you see one of these,
you know
you're in accessory mode.
You go dig through
those USB descriptors.
You find your first bulk "in"
and your first
bulk "out" endpoint.
Remember,
those are the workhorses.
This is where
your data's going over.
You set your configuration to 1,
and now you're ready to go.
You're gonna get
that same dialogue you saw,
and you're gonna be able to have
a two-way communication
through the app.
So now how do you communicate
with the app?
I'm gonna hand back over
to Mike "API" Lockwood,
and he's gonna let you know.
Lockwood: [chuckles]
Lockwood: Okay, um, we actually
have two different versions
of the accessory APIs.
Um, this is
a little bit confusing,
but we did this so we could
have accessory support
both on, um,
Android 3.1 and later
and also on Gingerbread.
So on Android 3.1,
we've got a new package
called android.hardware.usb,
and this is used for both
the host and the accessory APIs.
Um, if you know
that your app is gonna be
Honeycomb 3.1 or later,
this is the best thing to use.
Um, this is on 3.1,
which is going out today on Xoom
and will be on other--
other devices.
Um, we also wanted
to get this working on phones
like the Nexus S here.
So we've got a, um,
compatibility library.
It's a different package.
The APIs are almost
exactly the same,
um, but since we couldn't add
any new APIs to Gingerbread,
you have to link against
this--this library.
And, of course, this is--
this library is gonna exist
in future versions
of Android, as well,
so you can use this if you want
to support Gingerbread
on--on up to the future.
And if you've got a Nexus 1
or Nexus S
with the latest update,
you've been secretly
walking around
with this in your pocket
for the last week or two
without realizing it.
Um, so there's
a couple steps here.
First, you have to make
the connection
between the hardware
and your application.
This API just basically
is a direct--
direct pipe from your app
to the hardware.
Um, and the way we do this is
there's some meta--
extra metadata
you attach onto your app
through the manifest
that describes
the kind of, um, accessory
you want to talk to.
And, um, when something
gets plugged in,
the USB manager will say,
well, I've got this--
this--you know,
this manufacturer name,
this product name,
and this version,
and it'll look through and see
what apps are available
that do that.
And then you get the dialogue
that came up that I--
also very similar things
happening
in the host API
as when I plugged in
the missile launcher.
We're kind of doing
the same thing.
Based on what gets plugged in,
we say what apps are available
to do that.
Then finally, um,
once the user clicks "okay"--
and you can also say
always use this app,
so it doesn't keep asking you
over and over again.
Um, if you have an activity
that started
with a USB accessory
attached to intent.
And attached to that
is information
about the accessory that you can
communicate with.
And then finally, there's
another intent that gets sent
when you get disconnected.
Um, so here's
a kind of quick example
of what you'd put
in your manifest.
Um, you have to have an activity
that, um,
registers for the USB accessory
attached intent.
And then there's
a metadata thing
that basically links
to a separate XML file
that describes which accessory
or accessories
you can--you can talk to.
And the file--that XML file
would look like this here.
There's a USB accessory,
and you can say, um,
"manufacturer
'Acme Corporation,'
model USB Anvil, version 1.0."
Um, if you leave out
the version,
then it would kind of be
like a wild card
for any particular version.
Um, same thing with the model--
if you wanted--
if you want to work with
anything from Acme Corporation,
you can just omit the other two.
And you can list
multiple ones here
if you have an app
that can work with a number
of different things.
It's pretty flexible.
Um, and then there's
two classes.
The API is very simple,
especially, you know,
compared to the--
the host APIs are--
a lot more going on
on the host side
than the device side,
so this side's pretty simple.
There's a UsbAccessory class
that, um, describes
all the string fields
that get passed
from the hardware
up to the--up to the framework
that identify what it is--
Manufacturer, Model.
Uh, user-visible description
is what we show
in the dialogue box
when something gets plugged in.
The Version. There's a URL
you can use
to point to your web site,
that you can go to for
information about the accessory
or to download the app.
Um, and then there's also
a serial number,
which is optional,
but if your app
really wants--
needs to keep track
of individual-specific pieces
of hardware,
you can do your unique
serial number here.
And it's the Manufacturer,
Model, and Version
that are keyed upon
to choose the application
for the accessory.
Um, and then there's
the USB manager class,
which is used for both the host
and the accessory APIs.
The accessory-related calls
are getting a list
of the attached accessories.
You know, right now
there can only be one,
since there's only one USB port
on those devices,
but maybe that'll change
in the future.
Open Accessory gives you
a personal file descriptor,
which is an Android class
that encapsulates
a file descriptor
that can get past
to proc--
process boundaries
with binder.
And then from there,
you can actually, you know,
talk to the accessory.
Then there's also a couple calls
for getting permission to talk
to the hardware.
The user--for example,
the user doesn't click "Okay,"
but then later
launches the app,
and you want to connect
to the--the hardware,
you can use these APIs to bring
that dialogue back up,
um, to get permission
to talk to the hardware,
um, which brings up
an interesting
kind of difference
between how this works
and a lot of other things work.
There's no permission you put
in your manifest.
Like, for the camera,
you have to say this app
talks to the camera,
or this app wants to talk
to the GPS.
Um, and for USB, it didn't make
as much sense,
because you don't want
to say this app can talk
to any possible USB device.
So instead, it's kind of
dynamically chosen.
As the user clicks
on the dialogue,
it says this app can talk
to this hardware,
but you don't have access
to every single device.
It's kind of a finer-grained,
more dynamic permission system.
And finally here--
here's the--the sample
of how you, um,
you know, talk
to the accessory itself.
When you get started,
you'll get started
with the accessory
attached intent.
you can call getIntent
from your activity
to get the intent.
Um, and then there's
the helper function here
that gets the, um,
USB accessory object
out of the intent.
This is, um, needed
for the compatibility API.
Um, the--the 3.1 API,
you can just call intent,
getParcelableExtra, to get
the object directly that way.
Um, then you call openAccessory
to get the parcelable
file descriptor.
getFileDescriptor gives you
a standard file descriptor.
Then you get an input stream
and an output stream
by opening the file descriptor.
And then you can just read
and write data
using input and output streams.
So basically, the accessory
looks like a file.
And actually underneath, it's--
the file descriptor
just gives you,
uh, a file that--
directly to the kernel driver
that talks to the hardware.
So basically, read and write
like a regular file,
and you're sending and receiving
data to your hardware.
And then from that level up,
it's up to you.
There's no protocol defined.
It's just sending
and receiving bytes.
You can invent
your own protocol,
do whatever you want.
And, um, it's up to you.
So, um, I'm gonna turn it
back over to Erik,
who's got one more thing
to tell us all.
Gilling: All right,
well, if you felt like
we were rushing through this,
we sort of were,
'cause I can tell everyone's
kind of excited about this,
and we want to leave plenty
of time for questions.
But I think, uh, you know,
there's, uh,
there's one question
everyone has on their mind,
which is same as CNET,
you know--
"When are we gonna make
this available?"
Well, at least for everyone
in this room,
we've got 180K
for every one of you.
[cheers and applause]
Gilling: Well, applaud everyone
else who made it work, too.
Now not only do we have
the board that's in here,
we're giving you two servos
and all the cables you need.
So I want you guys to go out
and make all the next, best,
greatest Android accessories.
And now I'm gonna open it up
to Q&A.
[applause]
Gilling: Just stand up. Yeah.
So, uh, if everyone,
if you have a question,
could you please go to the mic
on other side of the aisle?
and that way, the recording
can get it, too.
man: Erik, when
are they getting the boards?
Gilling: When are you
getting the boards?
Ah, very important question.
man: [laughs]
Gilling: Uh, you'll be getting
a card as you exit the door,
uh, and then you can take
that down
to where you got your tablet
and your shirt and everything,
and you can exchange that
for one of these, uh,
cool white and green tubes.
Yes.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Gilling: Oh, can we get,
uh, the mic on over here?
man: This morning, I remember
mention of Bluetooth.
What's the APA
gonna be like for that?
Gilling: Well, right now, uh,
we have some fairly rich
RFCOMM-based Bluetooth support,
um, and so there's no ETA
for extending this API
into that.
However, it is
under consideration.
Brown: Well, actually, uh,
I mean, there's--there's fairly
rich Bluetooth API already, um,
but in terms
of human input devices,
the same support for USB
also works with Bluetooth,
so you should be able to use
Bluetooth MySQL keyboards
and joysticks.
Gilling: And J.K.'s here,
who's our Bluetooth guy.
Stand up and look embarrassed.
[chuckles]
[applause]
Gilling: Do you
have anything to add?
J.K.: [speaking indistinctly]
Gilling: I'm sorry?
Gilling: All right.
man: So you mentioned
the USB manager cost
had only, uh, support
for one device at a time,
but then earlier,
you were working
with both the keyboard
and the mouse and etcetera,
so was that
just available to you
or did I, uh,
misunderstand something?
Lockwood: Um, well,
it's kind of confusing,
'cause we've got both host
support and accessory support.
With host support, like a PC,
you can plug in multiple things
into a PC really easily.
The accessory support
is where, um,
you're talking over to the--
over the--
this connection here,
which is not host,
so it only can connect
to one thing at a time.
So maybe in the future
if we build a phone
with multiple ports
in the bottom or something,
there'd be a way to do it,
but right now,
it's just one at a time
for the accessory side.
man: So let's say
I wanted to make something
like an oscilloscope
where those, uh,
fairly high data rate,
sampling rate that was needed,
a lot of data coming in,
um, can I do that with--
with the bulk mode,
or would I need this nightmarish
isochronous mode to do that?
Brown: [laughs]
Gilling: Uh, well, I mean, as--
as far as I understand it--
I haven't dealt with
isochronous mode before--
um, is it's more about
guaranteed bandwidth
and not as much high bandwidth,
so...
And everyone I know
that have used it
has said it's a real pain
to deal with.
So I would first go down
the bulk route
and see if that works out
for you.
man: But both are supported?
Gilling: Oh, the host?
man: Both of them are supported
in the APIs of this--
Gilling: Uh, do we
support isochronous?
Lockwood: Oh, we don't support
isochronous yet.
Gilling: All right, well,
there's another answer
to your question.
[laughter]
man: Thank you.
Gilling: Yep. Oh.
man: Hi. Uh, during the keynote,
we saw something about
maybe uploading an app
from the USB device.
Gilling: Right.
So I kind of glossed over that,
and that's my fault.
Uh, one of those strings
that your open accessory,
as part of
the enumeration handshake,
sends to your Android device
is a URI,
and that can be a web page.
It could just be any location.
And so what you do is when
you're building your device
and where you're ready to
release that, put a URL in there
that describes where
to get the software.
man: I wanted to see if you guys
are familiar with
the IOIO board,
and if that's the--the same spec
and everything.
They've been...
Lockwood: Um...
man: Preordering those
for a while.
Lockwood: That's quite
a bit different.
That's using ADB,
which has been--
ADB is the tool that's used for,
you know, debugging
and working with the SDK,
and that's available
on all Android devices.
Um, but it's not enabled
by default,
and we're not really
guaranteeing it's gonna exist
in its current form
forever and ever,
so it's not really supported
to use ADB for these purposes,
but until today,
that was the only way
you could really do
something like that,
so that's why IOIO
is using that.
man: I'll see if I can cancel
my preorder then. Thanks.
Gilling: No, no, no. Actually,
I can speak a little bit more.
We've been in touch
with those folks, um,
and--and it was--this was
inspired in part by that.
Um, and there's no reason why
your IOIO device,
or yo-yo I believe they call it,
can't speak this protocol.
So please keep it on order.
It's a cool device.
Lockwood: Yeah, I mean, it's--
depending on what
you're trying to do,
if it's for hacking
and hobbyist stuff, that's fine.
I just don't want people
to build, you know,
expensive commerc--consumer
things using ADB right now.
[laughs]
Gilling: [laughs]
man: Thank you.
man: Um, so the ADB--
or the ADK board, um,
is built around
the Arduino platform.
I assume you're releasing
the full, um,
the full firmware for that?
Gilling: Yeah, absolutely.
As I said earlier, the software
on the Android side,
the software
on the Arduino side,
the board files, the layouts,
the schematics, the bombs,
everything is available
on accessories.android.com.
man: Awesome.
Gilling: Yep. Thank you.
man: So, uh, USB On-The-Go
has been supported in tablets
under Android for a while.
Does this mean that
you guys won't lobby
to push that into the handset
space anytime soon?
As in, will we see a handset
acting as a real host,
USB host,
in the next couple years?
Gilling: So there's certainly
nothing to stop that.
Lockwood: Right.
Um, yeah, the APIs are there now
if--if a phone supports it.
It's really up to the OEMs.
I think one of the major
limitations is just power.
I mean, if you're providing
half an amp to--to something,
um, users will be confused
and think,
Oh, this is great,
until your battery dies,
and that's kind of
the main concern, I think.
Gilling: All right.
man: Yeah, I was wondering about
the availability of API 12.
You mentioned that's
what we'll need to use.
Timeframe on when that will be?
Gilling: You mean
from an SDK perspective?
man: Yes.
Gilling: I believe the SDK's
released now, yeah?
Lockwood: I think
this went out today.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Can a device,
an Android device
that is host-enabled,
can it behave as a d--
as a, uh,
an accessory device
that can work with the ADK?
Lockwood: If it has
USB On-The-Go, then yes.
man: Okay.
Gilling: Yeah.
man: Um, what's the setup time
to get
a USB connection established?
Gilling: Uh, a USB what?
man: How long is the setup time
to initiate
this whole handshake?
Gilling: Oh,
the whole handshake?
Because we do the renumeration,
it takes a little bit of time,
but it only happens once
on plug-in.
man: No, but how many--
how many seconds, though?
Gilling: I-I don't have
that number. I'm sorry.
man: Oh, okay, 'cause the reason
why I bring it up
is it seems like a solution
to the multi-accessory problem
is if you, um,
have multiple accessories
just kind of round robin
who they are, who's host
and who isn't.
Lockwood: OOH.
Gilling: Uh...
man: But that relies on
a fast setup time.
Gilling: Yeah, it sounds
very complicated
and probably breaks
the USB spec.
man: Well, I mean,
as far as complicated goes,
it's no worse than Token Ring
netbooks were years ago, so...
Gilling: Well...
Lockwood: [chuckles]
man: For any custom
Android accessories,
will there be any sort
of certification process
or something that has to be done
to--to get a stamp of approval,
or no?
Gilling: Uh, we don't have
anything planned out.
I think that's--
that's a feature, not a bug.
man: Cool.
[laughter, applause]
man: Yeah, typically
we have seen that, uh,
in the non-Android world
it was the LIBUSB that would
give the kind of interfaces
that your Android app,
Android space is using.
So what--do you have some kind
of a bionic LIBSEE now?
Uh, Bionic...
Gilling: He's talking
about LIBUSB.
man: LIBUSB, sorry.
Brown: Oh,
we're not using LIBUSB.
Gilling: Well, Mike--Mike can
tell you all about that.
Lockwood: Um, I still
didn't hear the question.
Gilling: Oh, he was asking,
uh, you know,
on a normal Linux system
you have LIBUSB
to do USB host stuff.
Lockwood: Oh.
Gilling: Do we have that, or are
we using something different,
or do we have a bionic version?
Lockwood: Um, well,
I guess in the Honeycomb
there's the--
the kernel provides
the file system USBFS.
It's something similar to LIBUSB
that gives you a CAPI,
and then the framework uses JNI
to, um,
with the Java APIs
on top of that.
We're not using the same LIBUSB
that's--that's out in the, um,
standard Linux distributions,
though,
mainly just for license.
We wanted
an Apache 2 solution for that.
man: Okay.
man: Yeah, I just wanted to
make sure that I correctly saw
that USB Ethernet adapters
are gonna be supported.
[laughter]
Brown: [sighs]
A couple of them
happen to work now.
[laughter]
man: Yeah. [laughs]
I-is there a way
we can get that list?
Brown: But they're not
officially supported.
Gilling: Oh. Oh, I know exactly
what you're referring to.
man: Yes.
Gilling: And it's
the other way around.
On, say, like the Nexus S today,
you can do tethering,
and your Nexus S pretends to be
a USB Ethernet device
to your laptop,
is what we had on the slides.
man: Yeah,
but the other way around
where you're in a demo,
and you don't want to rely on
the wireless connection
in order to demo,
for example, speech
or, you know, voice recognition.
and you end up getting
a "Can't connect."
Gilling: So the best thing
I can say
is there's no official support
for that right now.
Lockwood: Yeah, right now.
you can--you can do that
if you've got the route access.
You can, you know,
run ifconfig and bring up stuff
from a route shell.
man: And if you're doing a demo,
I encourage you to do that.
Lockwood: The framework doesn't
realize it's there.
It might say
"No internet connection,"
but really, it's working
because it's just sort of
a low-level hack,
but you might be seeing people
doing that at places like this
where Wi-Fi's not that reliable.
man: Uh-huh.
[laughter]
man: Okay.
man: So two questions--
Um, this may be a silly one,
but, um, does this affect
the power requirements at all
with respect to having to,
for example,
grab wake locks
while in the USB mode?
Lockwood: In which mode?
Are you talking about the host
or the--or the accessory?
man: Um, either.
I guess the accessory one.
Lockwood: On accessory mode,
the phone is actually
probably charging off
of whatever it's plugged into.
In the host mode,
it's the other way around
where the--the keyboard
or missile launcher
is drawing power from--
from your Android device.
So it's, you know,
part of the USB spec.
Whoever has the host
has to be a battery
for the other side of the cable.
Gilling: But I think also,
uh, what you're getting at
is specifically surrounding,
keeping the device
and the screen awake.
We don't take any explicit
weight--wake locks
on either side of the protocol.
Uh, so if you have
an interactive application
that you don't want
the screen to go to sleep with,
you should rely on the standard
Android way of doing that.
man: Okay. There's nothing
automatic. That's what I mean.
Gilling: No.
man: Okay.
Gilling: No--there's no tricks
up our sleeves there.
man: Okay, cool.
And the second question is,
Can you give us examples
of some real, um, accessories
that are being built
by some real companies?
What should we expect?
Gilling: Well, you saw
an exercise bike up there.
man: Okay, other than that.
Gilling: Um, yeah,
There's telepresence robots.
I mean, this is a very new
initiative for us.
What we want do is we want
to get the technology out there,
and you know, we want you all to
create the next best accessory.
man: Cool.
man: Can you enumerate
what devices
support host mode now?
Gilling: Um,
I can enumerate one,
which is our Motorola Xoom.
Lockwood: Motorola Xoom.
Gilling: Um... [laughs]
Brown: I think all
the fast follower tablets.
Gilling: Yeah, I think
all the fast followers.
This is--I guess
the real question is,
I don't know right now.
I would go to
accessories.android.com
and, uh, there would at least be
contact information there.
man: I'm back.
Gilling: Oh, yeah.
man: Uh, for the host example,
you showed a keyboard
and a mouse
where it was obviously
tying into the OS
and getting the information
to the application.
Is there something equivalent
for the device side,
where the Android is the device
and the accessory
is the peripheral to tie
into the OS features?
Lockwood: Um, currently,
the accessory API
is directly from the application
to the hardware.
Um, you know, so that's--
that's--that's,
you know, great for, like,
opening up a whole bunch of new
possibilities for developers,
but the things that are missing
are, you know,
like audio in and out.
Our input devices
over the accessory mode,
those are things that we're
considering for future versions
where we can tie it directly
into the framework
Android system itself.
man: Um, you just mentioned
audio in and out.
Um, on Honeycomb
with the isochronous mode
would, um, it be possible to do,
like, class compliant
USB audio in
with this protocol, or...
Lockwood: Um, well, we don't
have the isochronous support
in the API at this point,
so, um,
that isn't really something
you could do that easily,
do using isochronous.
Um, you could, however,
you know,
use the two bulk endpoints
and send audio data
using your own, um,
Homebrew protocol.
They wouldn't be compatible
with standard audio USB devices
that are out there now, though.
man: So at this point,
that's still TBD.
Lockwood: Yeah.
man: Okay. Thanks.
man: For us traveling,
do you foresee any problem
getting a tube with a
circuit board through security?
[laughter]
Lockwood: What's he say?
Gilling: Okay.
Wh-what time? Do you want me
to put it at ten minutes?
Brown: Don't put it
in your shoes.
[laughter]
Gilling: So five more minutes
or ten more minutes?
woman: Five more minutes.
Gilling: Okay.
Brown: Any more questions?
Gilling: All right, well,
in favor of expediency...
[applause]
Gilling: And to make sure
the next people
have enough time to set up.